get over here ray Jack nation you can
stay here by subscribing clicking bells
Super Bowl Sunday is coming up so you
want to click the notification bell to
get notified whenever we got one of
their many reactions going up on that
day anyway there's this trailer here
Mortal Kombat legends scorpions revenge
and I heard about this movie I think
they're doing like two animated features
actually something about like Warner
Brothers is producing a couple of these
I'm pretty sure to help gear up for the
live-action Mortal Kombat movie that's
coming out which will be r-rated so yay
yeah let's check this out I'm excited
for
[Music]
to decide it's like one of those DC
animated movies ornament reptile
yeah
Wow
awesome
[Music]
oh now red band trailer yes I'm
surprised he didn't lead with her
intention like gore is the most famous
character in mortal common
I'm excited for this the the director of
this I believe did assault on Arkham the
DC animated one and the right or worked
on one of those DC movies as well I
think it was the tight Teen Titans one
I'm not sure what to think yes get away
this this looks great the animation
style and the flare does remind me of
that but it also looks mixed in a lot
with sort of just a Japanese anime flare
throughout which is appropriate
considering the fact that this is
adapting Mortal Kombat the players that
have mainly honed in on our classic
Mortal Kombat characters a lot of times
when I pick up the games I'll be like
who's this guy but I was rememberin
classics like you see here scorpion
sub-zero Raiden Sonya Liu Kang Johnny
cake Johnny Cage so the main characters
they focused on were them it's called
scorpions revenge
mmm-hmm-hmm I didn't really get a clear
sense of how this is scorpions movie
because I was the thing that I found a
little bit odd when I heard the title of
this scorpion is not really a character
that I've seen portrayed as a main
character he's always like everyone's
favorite he's the coolest or whatever I
know that's subjective I'm just saying
no kind of objects if at the same time
so fast saw that Joe come in a mile away
John makes that same kind of joke every
time to the punch right there I wanted
to see something that showed a little
bit more of a clear-cut plot because
yeah this is pretty much a small combat
tournament Shang Tsung Shao Kahn I
wanted to see you like what makes this
scorpions movie but I didn't really get
the sense for that other than that
though in terms of a Mortal Kombat
adaptation I'm sure this would be really
awesome yeah well and I also guess I
doing a little bit of reading and
understanding that they're going with
the 2011 retcon version of the story
that goes back and recontextualizes the
first
three games at least I kind of wish this
trailer gave me a little slightly better
sense for what I mean this is gonna be a
movie it's gonna be a bunch of fight
scenes so I kind of wanted to know a
little bit more what the movie itself is
gonna do or be about other than get all
these people together to fight which you
know is gonna be the way that they solve
the conflict at hand but still I mean
yeah it does look super cool I wish we
got a red man so we can see some of
those finishing moves some of that gore
because I do think that that's like one
of the main things that attracts people
to Mortal Kombat but this looks don't
worry John we'll still get a yellow
dollar bill sign oh we will even though
there's no swearing or violence in this
tree this kind of reminded me of like
commercial for uh like a TV animated
special a little bit so I don't know I
thought it was alright I thought it was
alright well the thing is I trust the
filmmakers behind it like those DC
animated movies are in some different
pretty incredible films and their
trailers are usually not up to par yeah
and delivering the goods on you know
really demonstrating what's gonna make
this film awesome nine times out of ten
you see that the trailers just are not a
great representation so it's really the
filmmakers involved and a lot of the
animation style like I love being able
to see so much of this brought to life I
remember in that 90s when the movie came
out the first movie there was an
animated movie that nixed cartoon and
computer-generated fights you yeah it
was terrible it was awful I really hope
they don't do that or all of this yeah I
remember that one those experiments were
special yeah I kind of felt like in the
voiceover for this because in the Mortal
Kombat Theme song when they're naming
off the characters Sonya Blade Liu Kang
it's I kind of sounded like they were
doing that here in the montage of the
characters they're focusing on I think
this trailer is slightly playing into
nostalgia for the people who grew up on
this in the 90s I don't buy it
okay there's so many new characters in
Mortal Kombat now like you brought up
that this was more
like a rendition riffing on when they
sort of relaunched it everything they're
kind of showcasing here or all the
things that were really heavily
showcased in the 90s movie you know so
it seems like they're kind of playing
into that I hope that every character
gets a chance to be fully fleshed out
that's something that I think is really
cool that you can do with a lot of these
video game movies especially ones that
have a simple plot like this getting
people from all parts of the world to
come together for the tournament and
Mortal Kombat you know like Johnny Cage
sonya blades background and all that
could be a lot of fun and especially you
know with the fact that they have these
voice actors like joel mchale here is
Johnny Cage and for carpenters Sonya
Blade Steve Blum as Sub Zero and you
played spike in the English dub of
Cowboy Bebop so he's a wonderful voice
actor there's a whole bunch of voice
actors action those are the few John
Bailey's I'm sure maybe he knows all of
them yeah he can tell you yeah what do
you guys think of this trailer
are you excited for it keep in mind it -
it's like if you haven't yeah I think
the animation style of Mortal Kombat has
such incredible graphics and it's
cutscenes and whatever I can see some
people being a little resistant towards
this because the animation might now
look super appealing compared to that
but I think if you are familiar with the
DC animated films like a lot of times
the animation doesn't even look great in
the trailers and you watch the movie it
looks incredible so that's kind of the
same impression I'm getting here I'm
just a suck-up - Warner Brothers plain
and simple like that check what you
think of the trailer leave a comment
down below subscribe to the reel rejects
click that notification bell to go from
being rejected to being accepted
[Laughter]
catchphrase let's see if it sticks and
if I remember that and the next time we
shoot a new video hey download it falls
on the start of the staff 30-second
reviews for any films TV shows and or
trailers posting daily sometimes twice a
day covering a lot of stuff on there
that we do not cover here on YouTube
playing a lot of catch up on movies and
shows and such so follow us over there
and last but not least I like to end
this with a patron of the day shout out
to a man named Daniel Gallagher John
take it away Daniel I know you've been
training
and I want to fight you I think that we
could really be a good match up you know
I'm kind of skinny
you've been bulking up but you're
younger than me so I think we could you
know really get something going you know
do it live on YouTube make some super
chats and then you can take those and
filter them back into patreon perfect
business model plus you know we get to
hang out what we're gonna fight me and
Daniel we're gonna fight wooden these
are my super chats
yeah we're gonna livestream the fight on
our channel okay get some super chats to
like power our fight up so like the more
Daniel gets the more pumped he's gonna
get and the more I get the more pumped
I'm gonna get but you know we're really
gonna split it at the end because it's
all coming through the same place but
then Daniel he's gonna take his cut of
the fight money and pledge it back into
patreon so now I've explained the
shoutout John has taught improv classes
I have two children it's hard very hard
you